students and staff at Marion Earl
Elementary School in Spring Valley
surprised one of their neighbors with a
very special delivery they collected
to Christ the King Church's Pantry which
many students families also rely on
photojournalist Henry takai was there as
the school teamed up to give back
we're going to start loading it over
onto the cart it's really important for
our community you know because we talk
about that service we talk about
gratitude we talk about giving back
we're going to my class first our class
had over what 600 items we do have a
handful of families that do use that
food bank at Christ the King Catholic
Church which is right around the corner
from our school
that makes me feel great because that
makes me feel like everyone is just
coming together and helping each other
and helping other families that don't
have enough so they can enjoy the
holidays with their family I'll get the
cans right here we show our thankfulness
and our gratitude and that's a way that
we can give back as a school and also to
show those families that we support them
if you want you can put some cans in
here I'm happy that like I'm in class
but I'm happy to do like the entire
video so we learned teamwork we got the
team of three sometimes my family will
be in like the best situation so they
will be like depending on their last
savings for life and I I don't want
anyone else to feel like that it's like
a huge amount and I was like really
surprised that that my class donated a
lot to help the community especially
people out there probably don't have
like enough food or they just need
something so when we just all help
together we can just help those people
that can't that don't have enough so
they can enjoy their holidays with their
families last year we collected a little
little over 1 000 and that was a record
this year we did 1600. this is a big box
of cans what is that oh a Ramen and
this is amazing I mean just just seeing
all the Outreach of people giving it's
just a beautiful thing we appreciate
everyone that has helped us out in the
community our kids get to take ownership
it's just so heartwarming especially
during the holidays